a surge in Amazon share price made the
company's founder the world's richest
person for a few hours Jeff Bezos
yesterday jumped as Microsoft founder
Bill Gates it was the first change at
the top of the Bloomberg rankings since
2013 the net worth for Bezos was
estimated to be more than 92 billion
dollars but Amazon's quarterly earnings
missed estimates that sent the company
shares lore and return gates to the top
position Jeff Fleur is here to explain
why industry insiders say Bezos won't
stay number two for long
Jeff good morning Charlie good morning
to you 22 years ago Jeff Bezos was
selling books out of his garage
yesterday for a time his net worth
jumped 2.4 billion dollars the company
he founded keeps growing keeps spending
and has become an entrenched part of
American life welcome for a brief time
Thursday Jeff Bezos was the wealthiest
man on the planet thank you Bezos owns
about 80 million shares of Amazon and
its stock has been surging helping the
53 year-old add to his personal fortune
by a said twenty four billion dollars
this year alone you cannot invent and
pioneer if you cannot accept failure it
could be a tug of war for a time for the
title of the world's richest between
Bezos and its Pacific Northwest neighbor
the man atop the rankings Microsoft
founder Bill Gates I think it's probably
inevitable you know with Bill Gates
giving away a lot of his wealth
Brad stone is a senior executive editor
at Bloomberg News he says Amazon's
impressive growth will likely land Bezos
at the top people expect things from the
richest person in the world to have an
active anthropic life Jeff Bezos isn't
there so people I think are gonna be
watching very closely at how he will
handle the extra scrutiny come on and
you can all word a better discipline it
it's a symbol of spending money on
things that matter to customers and not
spending money on things that don't
what's with the Honda but don't be
fooled in the 18 years since that's 60
minutes interview Bezos has been busy
spending I saw about a billion dollars a
year of Amazon stock and I use it to
invest in blue
founding space-exploration venture Blue
Origin the reason I finally bought it is
because I think it's an important
institution snapping up the Washington
Post in 2013 for a quarter billion
dollars and just last month agreeing to
acquire upscale grocer Whole Foods for
nearly 14 billion the market kappab
amazon has made you the second
wealthiest person in the world second to
Bill Gates can you imagine at some point
in your life pursuing the kind of
philanthropy well yeah thing left after
I finished building Blue Origin basis
did issue a request via Twitter for
philanthropic ideas in June it produced
a flood of responses in the meantime
Amazon has said it will create 100,000
full-time jobs in the US by next summer
many of those hirings Amazon said just
this week will be on the spot at job
fairs across the country a lot of people
I know think he's the best CEO in
America it's amazing the breadth of what
they're doing he always thinks outside
the box no and I think if you want to
innovate you got to be prepared to risk
failure yeah well I like the idea that
these massive huge companies who are
thinking about jobs 100,000 new jobs
right next summer that's great you go
Jeff Bezos yeah very nice thank you Jeff
Glor